hello you're watching the daily climate
show on sky news coming up on today's
program
consumers are left with a bill of
billions by some companies exploiting
the need to fill gaps in the electricity
supply
madagascar braces for an approaching
tropical cyclone as it struggles to
recover from flooding and landslides
last month
the beijing winter olympics gets started
claiming to be the first carbon neutral
games questions over the impact on the
environment for me
[Music]
hello and welcome to the uk's only
climate news show where we track the
changes happening to our world right now
and challenge those coming up with
solutions
well while consumers are still taking in
the news that they will be paying
hundreds of pounds more on their energy
bills from april it's also emerged that
households are faced with a record two
and a half billion pound bill spent in
2021 to plug gaps in britain's
electricity supply
coal and gas-fired power stations are
often called on to supply extra
electricity when renewable sources like
wind and solar and not providing enough
for the national grid
the industry is now concerned that some
companies could be exploiting that
situation to make additional profits our
science and technology editor tom clark
explains
this is the electricity national control
center the display shows every power
generator high voltage line and
connection on great britain's grid
keeping a steady flow of electricity is
a constant balancing act and in recent
months a very expensive one
looking at the screen you can see nearly
half our electricity right now is coming
from wind power with a bit of nuclear
and gas making up the rest but on less
windy days engineers here have to buy in
extra electricity to fill gaps in the
electricity supply now normally that
costs around 2 million pounds a day but
recently the cost of doing that have
been rising exponentially
balancing the electricity grid cost
consumers 2.6 billion pounds in 2021
that's around 860 million pounds more
than in 2020 a 48 rise on an already
record year and just last monday we saw
the third most expensive day ever just
under 41 million pounds extra to plug
the gap
we have seen days that have cost between
30 and 65 million in the last single day
in a single day in the last few months
so the top 10 most expensive days we've
ever seen in the balancing mechanism
have all occurred since september
last year so we are talking orders of
magnitude above
above what we're used to
the surge in cost is partly due to the
gas price but on tight days national
grid has to ask plants that are standing
idle to start generating that includes
aging coal-powered plants which are
expensive to fire up the concern in the
industry is that other cheaper-to-run
gas-fired stations are pricing
themselves as high as coal and making
windfall profits on windless days
pricing seems very high compared to
normal and what we need to understand is
how much of that is related to the price
of gas given the international gas
crisis and how much of it is due to
potential bad behavior from generators
who quite frankly are taking the mick in
order to make excessive profits
concerned about the trend energy
regulator ofgem has written to
generators and national grid has
launched a review into market behavior
they can bid in whatever price that they
think is appropriate or whatever price
they feel that the market will will bear
so it is a competitive market we wanted
to make sure that the rules and the
mechanisms of that balancing market were
delivering competitive outcomes for for
consumers the review is expected to take
another month or two but gas prices are
likely to remain high as more renewables
continue to plug into the grid
in future battery storage new nuclear
plants or hydrogen power could fill the
gaps on windless gloomy days but until
then regulators will have to keep a
close eye on our rapidly changing
electricity market tom clark sky news
madagascar already recovering from a
devastating tropical storm is now
bracing for an approaching cyclone its
department of meteorology has forecast
the storm will hit the east coast on
saturday having already killed at least
one person in mauritius and caused
widespread power cuts along its path
well storm anna struck madagascar last
month triggering floods and landslides
you can see here where the storm passed
through the country
now the island is bracing for a second
extreme weather event a category four
cyclone tropical cyclone batsurai is on
calls to strike madagascar this weekend
and meteorologists are warning the 100
mile an hour sustained winds will make
it the strongest storm to hit the
country in four years skies john sparks
has the latest
this storm has already skirted the
islands of mauritius and reunion where
high winds knocked down electricity
pylons causing widespread power cuts
according to the madagascan weather
service batsurai is expected to make
landfall near the town of mahanoro and
wind speeds of over 200 kilometers an
hour are possible the equivalent they
say of a category 3 or potentially a
category 4 hurricane they are also
warning about torrential rains up to 600
millimeters which can cause all sorts of
problems like extensive building damage
widespread flooding and landslides
it's a particularly difficult period for
madagascar another major weather system
cyclone anna passed over the island just
two weeks ago claiming the lives of 58
and making 130 000 people homeless the
authorities declared a state of national
disaster after fields and rivers were
inundated by flood waters even low-lying
parts of the capital and tana narivo
were badly affected
the region is certainly vulnerable as
the number and intensity of these storms
increase
and that is a direct product say experts
of climate change with temperatures on
land and sea rising at an alarming rate
well now for a look at some of the other
climate news making headlines today
the transport committee is warning that
the tax breaks driving the popularity in
electric and hybrid car sales could
create a 35 billion pound loss for
motoring funds the government's aiming
to ban the sale of new petrol and diesel
cars by 2030
but there have been no plans to
supplement the tax revenue they generate
if the government doesn't take immediate
steps
to decide what its preferred option is
to fix this
35 billion pound black hole then you may
end up with a whole patchwork of local
charging zones and it'll be impossible
to put a national
charging policy in place and if that's
the case then where is this four percent
of the entire tax take gonna come from
what's going to fund not just the roads
but also the schools and hospitals which
are currently funded by motorists
poland has paid 45 million euros to the
czech republic to settle a long-running
dispute to expand the touroof coal mine
on the border between the two countries
czech prime minister peter fjalla was
fighting for the environmental rights of
his country claiming the mine sucks up
the underground water resources of their
neighboring villages the dispute reached
the court of justice of the european
union before they agreed compensation
for infrastructure upgrades and other
environmental safeguards
the eu commissioner for the environment
says the health of the world's oceans
must be a key priority in 2022. virginia
cincovicious says an ambitious agreement
is needed protecting biodiversity and
starting negotiations to tackle the
global crisis of plastic pollution
especially at sea at a un news
conference he said precious time to save
nature and the oceans has been lost due
to the pandemic
and an indian village is banking on tree
mortgages in a bid to go carbon neutral
by 2025 and boost the local economy
kerala's farmers face ailing business
droughts and flooding but in the village
of minanggadi farmers who plant and look
after trees can mortgage them for a
10-year interest-free loan from the
council those loans only have to be paid
back if any of the trees are cut down
now the beijing winter olympics kicked
off today and they are being heralded as
the first ever carbon neutral games but
environmental concerns remain as they
will also be the first to rely on almost
100 artificial snow with hundreds of
generators at the venue operating around
the clock for more than two months
also causing concern are the ice rinks
most of which are powered by potent
greenhouse gases uh we're joining me now
is tim kellerson who's an associate
professor of sports administration at
georgia state university lovely to speak
to you tim
beijing says these are going to be cobb
and neutral games the first how is that
feasible uh given that they're using 100
artificial snow
yeah well so much of this relies on um
as previous olympics have claimed to be
carbon neutral this one's getting much
closer uh but a lot of reliance on
offsetting um which has been the case
for quite some time i think what we're
seeing different with this particular
games is that they're
much less reliant on those
offsetting
um
devices and tools so i think what we're
seeing with beijing is a preview of
what's to come not just with
moving closer to carbon neutrality but
also this reliance on artificial snow
are you surprised that this is coming
from china which certainly it cop didn't
show itself to be a you know at the
forefront of the climate change movement
i'm not surprised uh mostly yes the
political and um uh
the geopolitical
structures and um
everything that goes on in china is
certainly concerning particularly with
the um some calls for greater leadership
from from all countries including my own
uh but
because the olympic a paralympic games
are the premier sporting event in the
world all eyes will be on china and
this is where a country can signal its
leadership in lots of different ways
including in sustainability
and what about more generally as as
climate change
takes hold
places that normally saw lots of snow
suddenly are seeing less snow could this
be an end for winter sports or
traditional winter sports
yeah well i think it depends on how you
define traditional i don't see the
winter olympics going away uh but i do
think
that beijing is a good uh indicator and
a good test run of how future olympics
will be uh because um sorry to interrupt
you tim but just what about actual uh
ski resorts so i'm thinking of you know
the alps or of course in canada or in
the us
yeah well certainly so the olympics will
always be able to put on events like
this they can rely and they can pay for
um artificial snow making but if you
listen to the athletes talking about um
you know their own
experiences on the slopes they're not
just thinking about themselves they're
thinking about future generations and
the health of outdoor and winter and
snow sports
in in the future so
i there is a
serious concern about the impact that
climate change is having on the ability
of you know local resorts or
just general you know mountain slopes
um
keeping
maintaining high levels of participation
which is necessary for the for the
health of the sport and and health of um
you know folks as well absolutely tim
great to get your thoughts thanks so
much tim kellerson there uh from georgia
state university
well finding replacements for plastics
in all walks of life will reduce both
pollution and our reliance on the
petrochemicals needed for production uh
in the latest of our series of climate
diaries uh we hear from notpla a company
making sustainable packaging from
seaweed
knobler is a sustainable packaging
startup we make alternative materials
out of seaweed and plants we hope to
replace single-use plastics and other
non-sustainable materials with our
products in the coming years
you might not know but a plastic bottle
for water a usual 500ml one uses about
half a cup of oil to make it and eight
liters of water this is a massive
sustainability issue
currently we have our original product
the oho which is a flexible packaging
for liquids that is in fact also edible
and that is used at events and marathons
so you might have seen it at a london
marathon filled with lucas eight and we
can also fill it with water or other
drinks
when you get a takeaway currently you
might not realize that that very nice
looking brown paper box actually has
thin plastic lining inside it and we
have replaced that with our material
which makes that box both biodegradable
but also recyclable
seaweed is a fantastic material it grows
in the ocean so it doesn't require fresh
water to grow and it doesn't compete
with food crops for arable land
packaging has a huge impact in terms of
climate change and if we can reduce the
amount of carbon released in the
manufacture of packaging then fantastic
[Music]
amazing stuff well do stay with us
because coming up on the daily climate
show i will be joined by the economist
vicki price and climate columnist for
the independent donica mccarthy we will
be discussing solutions to the
eye-watering costs of balancing our
national electricity grid and to that
potential black hole in public finances
left by the switch to electric vehicles
stay with us
[Applause]
hello and welcome back to the daily
climate show on sky news and we're going
to get straight into discussing the
climate issues of the day with the
economist vicky price and climate
columnist for the independent donna
mccarthy thanks very much to both of you
for being uh with us donica i'd like to
start uh with you the base load as we
heard earlier in the program uh isn't
being met by renewables at the moment
it's going to get more expensive to fill
that gap using oil and gas so how should
we be meeting our energy demands
well what we're looking at here is a
failure by the treasury to invest in in
renewable base load over the last 10
years and in insulation so it's actually
left householders vulnerable to
exploitation by the fossil fuel industry
at the moment and secondly it's less
than national grid vulnerable to
blackmail by the fossil fuel industry at
the moment um
wind electricity is now costing 40
pounds per megawatt it's 200 pounds for
for gas megawatts so what we need to be
doing is investing in green green
hydrogen plants
tidal tidal power and storage the
failure to invest in these type of gen
um electricity storage of the last 10
years have left us vulnerable to this
exploitation however there is some good
news because actually wind is now so
cheap it's actually i'm going to save
households three-quarter billion this
year and an estimated according to ssc
over the next five years something like
nine billion pounds going back to
consumers because of of the expansion in
wind energy
that's i mean that's interesting because
you're saying that there is still the
scope for renewables to fill that gap
vicki price would you agree there or do
you think we do need to fall back on uh
the traditional uh fossil fuels
well the problem is going to take quite
some time for renewables to really fill
the gap completely i mean there have
been days
recently where renewables um were not
making up very large part of the
electricity that was being used so with
gas perhaps in accounting for over half
of what we're using so that's a serious
problem so you need storage and that
storage is difficult to come by i agree
that we haven't invested enough in it
there are all sorts of ways in which
renewables can be stored but they cost
and they require quite a lot of
technologies which for some reason we
haven't necessarily invested in but also
they require some rather big grid
batteries
and again the investment needs to go in
there but until that happens we are
going to be relying quite significantly
on those gas-fired power stations
sometimes even coal fired power stations
to ensure that at least electricity is
not interrupted because unfortunately
what happens with renewables is that
they're very intermittent they you can
suddenly have new wind and the sun will
not shine what do you do then
i mean donica what do you what do you
make of that do you think you know for
you do you think this could actually be
an opportunity for us to move towards uh
investment in renewables but but even
more widely on this idea of the base
load do we need such a high base load
very good question i mean one of the in
my job as an eco auditor i visit
businesses charities homes where we are
heating lighting and cooling
empty rooms empty spaces what we really
need to question as you rightly raise is
why are we such a high base load nobody
talks about that the actual cost in
terms of putting an infrastructure to
cover the base load is extraordinarily
expensive in terms of infrastructure
investment however every kilowatt of
electricity not used is free and save us
to save us all so what i think we need
to be doing is a major program of energy
efficiency not just in um
in infrastructure and in installation
but actually in practice we need to
train the public and our businesses how
to use energy efficiently we must not we
must stop leaving the air conditioning
and heating on overnight in our in our
homes in our businesses and in our in
our tower blocks how could we do that do
you have any sort of practical solutions
as to how we could better manage that
well a timer
i have uh i've gone to charities and
they've left the the heating on all week
all night all weekend and just a simple
timer can cut their um their carbon
emissions for heating by around 40 to 50
percent a simple timer can actually be
really effective and i would ask any any
viewer who's actually at work make sure
the timer and temperature for their
operation is set correctly and please
make sure they're not air conditioning
and heating empty spaces
vicky i wonder what you make of what
donica just said do you think that's
enough to tackle the root cause or is it
simply not it's just a sticking plaster
at this stage
i think energy efficiency is key there's
no doubt about that it's key for homes
is key for buildings and it's absolutely
true that when builders are unoccupied
one shouldn't leave all these things on
um but however we do have a very very
old housing stock and it takes a lot of
effort and a lot of money to improve
that installation so uh we've got a long
way to go i'm afraid we're going to be
relying on that baseball we've been
talking about for quite some time i
absolutely agree i think we will be
talking about that for quite some time
so we will leave it uh for this evening
and move on to our second uh topic with
our two guests uh which is of course as
the country shifts from petrol and
diesel cars to electric vehicles the tax
income for the treasury will reduce less
car tax and less duty paid on fuel that
makes a 35 billion pound hole to fill
that's according to the mps transport
committee the committee says filling
that gap is something the government
needs to grapple with and fast uh well
let's go back to our guests and vicky
i'd like to start with you uh on this
one
do you think we need to move to a
european model when it comes to roads uh
i'm thinking about tolls for for road
users for example
remember the tools that they've got is
mainly on motorways
and not all countries have that either
so it varies from place to place um what
i think the committee is thinking of is
in fact charging by the mile possibly uh
in towns as well we already have of
course the congestion charge and other
things that people have to pay when they
get into the center of towns but of
course it doesn't generally apply much
to electric vehicles or at least there
are all sorts of exemptions out there
the interesting thing is that indeed
there is a lot of money which has been
collected by fuel duty uh of course vat
on petrol as well and then you add to
that the the tax that you pay to just
have a car and indeed there will be a 35
billion hole but only about 7 billion of
that goes to improving the road so
basically what drivers are doing and i
don't know why drivers have to pay for
this they're paying for a lot else that
goes on in the economy there is no real
reason for that if the government wants
to get
revenue to pay for other things like
schools and the general is a welfare
system that we have then he should do
something different and redistributes
you know a tax take in a different way
raise income tax if necessary that's
very interesting i mean donica what do
you make of this of this idea that
electric vehicles should not uh be taxed
do you think that's enough to
incentivize uh all of us to get an
electric vehicle and is that the right
strategy
good strategy whilst we're encouraging
to transition but once we've actually
achieved the transition then it makes
sense to introduce road charging we have
to actually we cannot just switch all
our fleet over to electric vehicles a
because the amount of electricity
required is is mind-boggling and
secondly we need to improve the
economies of our towns and cities we
need to tackle congestion we need to
tackle pollution and we need to tackle
safety and what road charging does it
differentiates between congested cities
and rural rural rural streets for people
living in rural areas the vast majority
of the public lives in urban areas and
so road charging really makes sense
there to discourage um uses of cars and
to move people to more healthy styles of
cycling walking and using public
transport it's not
the the committee's right to be looking
forward and to be planning for when
we're reducing the tax take from fossil
fuel cars however we must not think that
we can just switch over to electricity
and that solves all their problems
because for example just the tires alone
i i where an estimate of something like
12 12 times the size of whales will be
felt in rainforest to produce the rubber
for electric vehicles and and fossil
fuel vehicles so we need to reduce the
number of cars as well as switch the
essential vehicles over to electricity
okay vikki just to go back to your to
your point you made uh earlier as well
who do you think should be paying for
the upkeep of the road should it be just
the diesel and the petrol uh guzzling
cars or should other people using those
roads be paying for them as well
but the other people of course include
cyclists include pedestrians uh and of
course they also have uh something to
benefit from if the roads are run you
know are kept to the standard that
should be kept uh you know potholes
affect poor cyclists quite considerably
so yeah i think the general population
in other words needs to pay for this but
we should not confuse uh they couldn't
the type of paying per mile which is
really more for congestion to anything
we charge motorists for paying for
general
upkeep of everything else in the economy
i think everyone who uses the roads
needs to pay something for them and i
think that should be part of the general
taxation system donica in a word uh
quickly i know you're a cyclist would
you be happy to pay for for the use of
the roads
well we have to remember what what cars
are currently playing they're not paying
road tax they're paying pollution tax
and actually what that is actually is to
counter what roads what drivers need to
pay for is a damage that they're doing
to society as well as the actual right
to use the road and so that's why we
have to continue charging uh road
drivers taxes and not charge pedestrians
or cyclists taxes because we they're
it's what we want to encourage for a
safer healthier community donica thank
you so much i'm afraid we're going to
have to leave it there we're all out of
time great to hear from both of you uh
donnica mccarthy and vicky price thank
you and before we go remember you can
download climatecast wherever you get
your podcast this week anna and katarina
are getting glitzy uh they're talking
cly fight that's right climate fiction
they'll be hearing from the producer of
amazon's show the expanse and from
professor michael mann friend to this
show and apparently the inspiration
behind leonardo dicaprio's character in
the netflix hit don't look up uh well
thanks very much for watching uh we will
see you next time
[Music]